Versus right now. Okay, but let,
let's tell me how the connection
between aliens and the Nazis took place.
When did all this start? Let me, let
me begin. Cause this just really,
I'm telling you, Joe, there's just a real
deal. I believe you. This is you ask,
who are they?
It's people who are psychically,
genetically available to interface in
this incredibly diverse universe with all
these dimensions above and below and
all around us with consciousnesses.
And the truth is no energies ever
destroyed. It all continues on.
The truth is our bodies.
This is a fact or a communal hive organism
of all of our ancestors and all of
their race memories,
but not in just some compressed
epigenetic system. It's beyond that.
It's an electro chemical antenna.
They've proven this,
that connects to higher
and lower dimensions.
Show our body shoot czar
cause our, our, our,
our predessessors would put us in a
position without giving us a bodysuit.
That is them. Our families are
loving us. They're holding us,
they're wrapped all around
us. Their strength or we'll,
they're bad. They're good,
their sins, the good things they did, the
battles, they won, the battles they lost.
The woman they love, the the man they
love. It's all in us. All these people.
It's while we're able to look into so
many things and have so many different
experiences, and so all the
showman, all the ancient religions,
everybody says there are the good ones
and there are the bad ones and the,
and people are interfacing. So
you say, where does it begin?
From the Tibetans to the Mezzo Americans,
the Egyptians to the drudge,
to every ancient society
describes the same thing.
There are bad things that look like els
that have horns when they show you who
they really are and there are good things,
but they don't contact you unless
you contact them and then they,
they're almost not even
concerned with what you're doing.
I never bought into this look to do it,
but then I began to think about what I
hear when I was a kid. What did I see?
What was coming on?
Government documents,
what was being admitted when I read all
these books about World War II and the
Nazis and Hitler obsessed with the Dalai
Lama and the Tibetans and what they
were able to do without drugs to interface
with this and all the rituals they
would do and how they were
believed that beyond the ether,
like at skull and bones,
it's a German death coat.
They do rituals and take drugs
to talk to the goddesses. Well,
there's just appearing as you
know, sexy, beautiful women.
It's whatever you want as the spirit
guides because lower entities will come in
and violate your freewill
God and his angels,
which are below him will not get
involved in your everyday life.
They will not manipulate your
freewill unless you asked them in.
But then the devil masquerades as an
angel of light. So we're on this planet.
The third dimension,
which is a launch pad,
all the other dimensions below
and above the third dimension,
all the bathetic shows is,
is the primal see of where all this
happens in the earth, like an egg.
And we've got all this potentiality and
God will send out a transmission for a
larger plan, but evil is willing to come
in and what does it say? Demoralize,
get rid of children, don't
have kids. Humans are bad.
You will be will be better
once you're all gone.
And it's because it's their operational
mission for whatever reason that will
understand later what's going on. So
the Nazis, we get the deep literature,
they believed, they were basically
say on seeing and, and, and,
and being possessed by entities that,
I mean it was before the
Nazis for whatever reason,
it was the Germans that this happened to.
And the Swiss,
like they didn't discover
Lsd in the thirties these,
these people were running
the psychology departments.
They were interfacing with the occult.
They were involved in all this crazy
stuff and it was all about their power and
how great they were going to be in
the Germans were seduced and they were
seduced because they had high iqs.
But more than that,
they were psychically connected to
each other and would work like robots.
The this Chinese and the EU want robots
replaces cause they'll follow orders and
the Chinese are very conscious
when they're conscious.
They're also very robotic.
But the Germans are just as robotics.
So this entity system pick Germans
as its attempt even in World War One,
World War II.
And it was been to putting the bricks
as well and offering them technologies,
but two different paths.
One was social control and also
their stuff with the Brits.
The other was high tech weapons, uh,
systems interdimensional with the Germans.
And so whoever these players are, and you
can dial into it, it's very dangerous.
They're manipulating the British
arm versus the German arm.
And then they've got the
Chinese arm that's almost
seem to like their robot army.
And, and, and, and so when you study it,
the globalist go to these events and they
take bigger and bigger doses of drugs,
they do electroshock.
Uh,
if you go about the owners of time life
books didn't work just in the twenties
and thirties and LSD and other
hallucinogens and apothecary,
they were dealing electro
shock. They were, they were,
they were having people turn their heart
off to like try to communicate with
these things,
to try to be dominant and get that.
So you go back thousands of years, Merlin,
you know, the archetypal or, or, or,
or these magicians or these,
these wizards are taking drugs in these
temples and interfacing with these
Palentier is these crystal balls,
which aren't really crystal balls.
It's their psychic focus
of an interdimensional
connection while they're on
drugs, looking into glass to then be able
to see the future and understand what's
happening to give them temporal
power over this planet.
But like the Bible tells
you any pharmacare,
any of that always leads to destruction
because only evil is going to come
through that way. So we're
basically have these light sockets.
We can't Jack into the higher lets
us our free will and that takes time.
We Jack in to the evil so
you can Jackie into evil.
You can't Jack into good right
away. So it's quicker, it's easier.
Like Yoda says about Darth Vader,
quicker, easier, more seductive.
And so then I remember being a kid and,
and and my parents,
they don't really get mad about this.
It's whatever they even know what
they were hearing at the time.
But they had friends that they knew
at ut that we're involved in research
projects and then,
and then they were nine times out of 10
are worried about research projects in
San Francisco. Ut has some, MIT
has a lot and me anytime you want,
but this was in like the 60s they had
virtual reality gloves where you'd put
them on and put goggles on and you'd go
into stuff that looked like the Holodeck
from Star Trek 20 years forward existed
and they were doing surgeries and all
this and they would do empathy
loads where they'd say,
we need the public because we're so
weak because the west is so strong.
People haven't had trauma, so
they sold them low level. Oh,
we're going to create trauma.
Like when you go to Mars,
you're not getting any gravity. So your
hearts don't get when you get there.
Who's organizing all this? Well,
they don't tell you. They go, oh,
it's a special class. You've
been. Gotcha. So in the 60s,
they had closed a special class of
people that are organizing all this shit.
It's the highest scores, but is
it's for, for, for what purpose?
No financial gain.
Social Jack Parsons, uh,
was the jet propulsion laboratory.
Alistair Crowley. Devil worship. Exactly.
So you're still in chat alley
over a hundred years ago,
the aliens given the guy, the
founder of JP Arrow, Jack Parsons.
Have you heard this before?
No.
I just can't believe I didn't
want to have Alex on the Pi,
but did not let me finish. Just let
me say this. Not trying to take over,
but who just got here, but I'm
not bullshitting you. Okay.
I'm telling you this stuff.
I don't believe in this.
Okay, here it is right there.
This is patented in 1957
CVR machine. Exactly. No,
exactly crazy show.
I've told the people not just family,
Holy Shit and gives you wind
vibration, aromas, stereo sound power,
motion wide vision and three d three
dimensional. But let me tell you,
they wore a mask in the sixties and
seventies that was already like you.
She like paper, thin TV screens and
it was all ready. I talk to her.
They said there's no way
this was human technology.
So you've seen these
foldable phones? Yeah. Yeah.
I think the aliens have already
taken over Samsung and Huawei. Yeah.
Do you think the aliens
are taking over Samsung?
Do you have any something
to do with Samsung will?
Obviously that's what
I'm telling you is the,
the Pentagon isn't worried about it
as long as Jamie says the patent. Wow.
I notice that's the reach
of the sixties I believe.
1957 so notice that's
exactly what you're buying.
That's what my dad told me. That's
what our HTC vive looks like. The day
my dad didn't tell me this chill,
he shot end game and he said,
no son.
We had virtual reality goggles and we
had shooty rom and we had things and then
something else happened,
and I'm not at liberty to get into it,
but I was shown three years ago what
the University of Washington was doing
under Bill Gates, and this is
in the 90s what were they doing?
What do you do? They, they don't
even know what they're being given.
It's intervening ish.
So you think it's some sort of alien
intervention type shit, dude, they, they,
okay.
They to get even deeper,
they turn your heart off for five
minutes and they pump oxygen into your,
and you're in the meetings.
I've talked to people that are involved,
I mean top scientist and you're in
the meetings with fricken aliens.
Elves is the main group, but they're
like, oh, by shutting your heart off,
it makes you have that
psychedelic experience by
keeping blood in your oxygen.
It's keeps you alive. But we'll,
we'll, we'll, let's explain. Okay.
The heart goes out, the body thinks it's
dead. Right? So you can stay in longer.
I don't know all the science behind it.
I understand. But let's explain this.
Lucky DMT or Iowasca 200 times.
But mostly like most of our astronauts
to test pilots are flying planes.
Those are robots. Cow. It's all
mind war shall these dudes are like,
it stops working once you've
taken in hundreds of times.
So then they start taking their most
psychic people who are able to do this and
they turn their heart off and
then they put them into these,
these events and it's like the
things the aliens tell them,
they come out and they tell scientists
and it works show like we're going to
shit. They didn't let me tell you
get killed for this stuff Joe.
This is not the only thing
they want me off the,
because when I finally figured this out,
cause I never touch aliens,
I kind of knew the whole thing already.
Here's what I'm talking about.
When I was a kid, wait nine,
whatever it was, this woman,
this lady would come
over that had known my,
my parents had UTI and was
involved and she talked about,
yeah we call it the psychedelic
research should or whether the name was,
but it's really a CIA deal.
And you know,
we just can't find people
that can handle it.
They're going in the hills want this,
and he yells,
want us to basically reduce population
and agree to these certain plans and it's
all about humanization. And they call the,
it's clockwork hills and they're like,
yeah, this is my parents. You're
like seven, eight years old.
Like they don't think you're
listening talking about,
well this is what the elves want and
this is what they're going to do.
And the thing is, he's not,
parents aren't that special.
You go out to San Francisco
that it's all there is dude. It's
a cult man. You all these guys,
you know from San Francisco,
dude, you look at,
look at the head of Google or youtube
or fricking apple. He's on TV.
Tim Cook in his eyes are
this big under lights, man.
These guys are on stuff
that like nobody even knows.
What do you think they're on
stuff they've been given. I mean,
I know people at ut,
they won't tell me specifically,
but I was telling you to do two owns
youtube. Who's that guy? What's his name?
Girl. You sexist pig. Alphabet.
Alphabet is the parent company who
this is their take take, take patellar,
any dude. There's not like a Jack Dorsey
of youtube take, take, take, take.
Sundar Pichai sorry. He goes in Congress.
I'm there. He's the CEO of Youtube.
He's a CEO of Google. Google, sorry.
And he's literally on TV going,
we never fixed the result.
We don't spound anybody.
There is no surveillance and you've got
all these old white men and I want to
say it,
I'm white men to be trendy.
It's all a bunch of old dumb ass white
men and a couple of dumb ass old Mexican
and black ladies. They're
all dumb. Normally call,
they are going show you
don't spout it or control it.
Meanwhile their own perspectives to their
shareholders and how they control it
all, now they're going to deliver
maximum profit. And Sundar is like,
yes it is true. We have never controlled
the search result and it's just,
I'm just listening to pure lies.
Meanwhile,
this guy's only the front guy of Eric
Schmidt and God knows what they're into.
They're, I mean, it hasn't been
proven that Google does something to,
to alter search results.
Uh,
I'm asking cause I don't know. I'm
not asking to fuck with you. Uh, yeah,
no know what did they do?
Who will itself is about if you pay them,
they put your results at the
top. Just like Facebook. Okay,
well that's definitely altering search
results. So what he said was not true.
If they, if you can pay, it's like
saying water, watery, wet Joe.
I know you know all this
stuff. No, no, no, no. I don't
know that. I don't know that.
Now listen, I'm honest about what
I don't know. I know some things,
but I, there's a lot of fucking holes in
my knowledge base. That's a fact. Well,
you know that they tried to block my
name and direct it toward negative stuff.
I'm sure they do.
They manipulate.
All they do is all they do is the
negative. You attack me. It's,
it's digital currency.
You go to the top and they pay you money.
Some of your body, a little tip
watching a tapped me lie about me.
You go to the top.
But you'll lose your soul.